well as concerns over the uptick in
covet cases in southern nevada health
officials trying to prevent history from
repeating itself
we thank you for staying with us i'm
brian loftis and i'm denise valdez
face mass use returned as you know last
week here in clark county
christian casadas explains how one
doctor says we are not
out of the woods yet so the common mode
of transmission remains
a person to person transmission of covet
19.
that's according to dr apiksha desai
from optum nevada
who tells us one of the most common ways
to get the virus
is being exposed to someone who has
coveted regardless if they show any
symptoms
so i believe that if we are going to be
indoors in a public public and crowded
place
where we are unaware of the vaccination
status of other people
it still makes sense to continue to wear
a mask
and when possible continue to maintain
the social distancing
as las vegas brings back more
entertainment sports and even dining
dr desai says people can get carried
away and will drop their guard
even if they're vaccinated it doesn't
mean a hundred percent
like i said despite how good they are
they're not 100 protective you can still
get covered by
19 but your chances of getting very sick
or ending up in the hospital
are very very low today she is reminding
others to keep those hand sanitizers
close by
and practice social distance if possible
because the new variants like the delta
is highly contagious we in the united
states i think are pretty
uh fortunate that we have the
availability of vaccine and we have
health care resources but but even so we
want to be cautious and
and use the resources at our disposal
christian casa is 8 news now
if you need to get a kobit test there
are several locations available around
the valley testing sites will be open at
csn and henderson north las vegas west
charleston
tomorrow and through friday the southern
nevada health district also offering
covid testing throughout the week
more information about these sites and
other locations you can visit the
health district's website and there is
no plan or no word about any
potential shutdown